hello hello everybody welcome to to the
stream
i'm grandmaster mitchell partly grass
and i'm going to talk about the
games of the week and i'm going to
[Music]
uh to comment on the
[Music]
uh final uh final match between uh
hikaru nakamura and the maxim vashiala
graph
from the speed championship
so they played one hour and a half
five plus one blitz games then one hour
three plus zero and then finally half an
hour one plus one
bullet and i'm going to talk about the
games
uh from uh five plus one uh
uh that they played on uh
five five plus one blitz uh there were
ten uh ten blitz games like this well
i'm not um
i'm not going to be harsh on the players
i mean i just want to
um
uh i just want to to see the game and
yeah just let's enjoy the games so the
first game
uh hikaru nakamura bashir lagrav maxim
bashir lagrav
[Music]
white hikaru
he goes e4
c5 knight f3
d6 well it's well known that
maxim is going for
[Music]
for the neighbor
um most of the times
so he has a fixed repertoire but he
he's an expert in the niger so he knows
everything there
and
[Music]
it's a it's a good idea for
for hikaru to to try to play something
new
some some sound setup
in this kind of situations
so he goes bishop c4
and this is a quite quite a rare line
it's not considered dangerous
at least from my experience but
let's see let's see what's going on in
the game so knight f6
d3
a6
c3 well i guess he wants to get a setup
like in the
in the roy lopez um
so let's see i don't know where i
if i can show you with arrows here
trying to but
no way to show with the arrows but i can
make the moves on the board
okay bishop b3
uh e6 castle so
for now only only natural moves i see
here
not much to uh
to comment upon
we should be seven well also
um so i didn't even play e a4 or
something like that so
black has a nice black and a word some
nice development
on the other hand is not
is not celery here so knight bd2
bishop e7 rookie one i guess they were
playing this move
like very very quickly
here so d4
okay first major decision i mean he
could try to go
knight f1 knight g3 let's say but
he's just going for
for d4 97
bishop c2 okay the bishop goes into
position and now
maybe he is preparing to play e5
i'm not not sure let's
let's go on queen c7
and now he played e5
okay so he's going for e5
i think it's normal moves until here
i don't know how is the position i guess
it's about equal
[Music]
um
95 this is also normal
94.
well it's uh
it's logical most by um
by white but maybe here maybe here i
would prefer to
to take one e5 somehow take takes and
now
i don't know but white will still bring
queenie to
and
[Music]
try to to have some attack on the king
so
in the game he took she takes g4
and now
yeah now actually he was precise and uh
this is uh good to see in the police
game
um because i think he took on d6 i think
taking on d4 can be can be wrong because
it opens up the the c file and then
probably he can just take here take and
rook c1 attacking this bishop and
actually white white could be in trouble
so white
wouldn't like this c file to to be open
so okay in the game he played
he took on d6 but this is a
this is a good decision i guess
he's just uh taking the the pair of
bishops
queen d4 and okay
let's see now he has the hikaru has a
pair of bishops
and he could
he could have some threats on the on the
black's king
on the other hand also black has the
strong knight to to d5
so i don't know let's see
what is going on i mean it's a bliss
game
also white still has to to bring the a1
rook into play
so black goes rook aca logical move
not much to not much to comment here
so far bishop g5
interesting i would i would expect uh
this bishop g5 move if there was
a rook on d8 but probably it's
just as good i mean there were no other
no other squares available for the
bishop
and now he wants to to play maybe
rook 81 with a very nice position
and black girls i don't know
probably h6 is a difficult decision to
make
there is queen d3
something like f5
but i'm not sure about this
so i don't know he went rook c4
roxy 4 looks tempting especially for a
police game i would do it i'll do it
instantly
uh it just got the option to for the
queen to go
queen h4
so queen d3
g6 yeah but if he has to play like this
then maybe
maybe rook c4 wasn't so good because now
look at the look at the dark squares in
black's position they are very
they are very weak and black lacks the
dark square bishop
so rook 81
logical rook fc8
yeah on the other hand uh the c file is
closed so i would expect white to have
an advantage here
queen e2 probably he wants to
you know well he wants to open up the
the d file
so black goes queen f8
okay trying to
try to cover up the the dark squares
bishop b3 activating the bishop
yeah i feel i felt black should be
should be in big trouble here
queen d2 okay trying to get bishop h6
knight c5 bishop c2 but this is just a
blitz game
so i will skip this i will
fast forward it a little bit
95 yeah it seems just winning forward
so probably this was very easy rooks is
seven here
it's it's quite sad when you have to go
back to
uh when the rook has to go back like
this from where it came so roxy 7
knight g4 now
and
yeah plenty of threats on the dark
squares
h5 big decision but
i guess it's understandable well i
expect the game not to
not to last long
95 back
it makes sense maybe there were maybe
there were other moves
knight f6 knight f6 would
could be good as well okay but probably
yeah it just doesn't last too long okay
bishop
h4 avoiding some f6
tricks 97 ig6
wow well you have to take into account
this
is 5 plus five plus one
so very very fast games and
time for the decisive sacrifice
let's see how it worked rookie six
knight f8 well
i guess he missed that because now
now it's not it's not clear at all so
this this knight g6
here was uh
was not required i guess all right
now the game now the game starts all
over
rook d6 d7
take take
queen g5 yes now again
knight e5 okay look
rookie located since was
the move here because 90 night here
there was a strong one bishop before
okay f4
still tempting to push to push forward
everything
93 probably they they were making
mistakes here but i shouldn't comment
because it's
very low time on the clock check
that was not necessary rook c5
yeah now
i don't know it still should be good for
for white but queen h6 i think the
ending
is is just fine for for black
they take h4
what and game over
well i guess i guess
they were already down to seconds here i
mean rook d2
just just loses probably the position
is i don't know he could try g5
he could be even he could be even better
here
but uh rook d2
well it must be a shock
uh okay so this was the first game
let's move on to the next one it's
difficult because they were playing
non-stop they they didn't have time they
didn't have breaks in between
here we go e45
so they go for the berlin
[Music]
icar is playing the berlin very very
often
and he is confident in it
and maxim is going for
for the ending i guess yes maxim
analyzed
the ending and i guess he knows he's not
giving anything for white but
he probably knows it very well and
it can be dangerous especially in blitz
games
okay this is all uh well-known stuff
in the berlin rook d1
logical moves but it's supposed to be
to be okay for black rock h6
actually maxine played this uh
several times before even
he had an important game against
grieschuk
are the candidates this year
i think it was a draw but maxim was
winning
so rookie one this is the point
i guess there is another line here with
the g
g s read and after after it then uh
something like this bishop g5 bishop
and rook g6 and uh
h4 f6 well many many games
another another main line but okay he
prefers this
this is more this is less clear
we should be four h3 bishop
takes point x h4 yeah it makes sense to
block the position so
as far as i remember this is the game
against the greystruck
g4
well he has he has to go for g4 because
otherwise uh i mean he has to set the
spawns in motion
take take 97
h4 yeah this is uh
this is well known
knight d5 bishop c1
okay and here i here i guess there are
two two main moves there is
knight i think
i think grish2 went for 1993 in the
candidates
and there is b5 that was played in the
game but
as you may notice it's difficult to play
these dispositions in uh
in a bliss game so they play five five
plus one
games and you of course you need to
remember this immediately not to
not waste time and the position is still
tricky
the position is still tricky c4
pawn takes
so now he's going he's going after this
c port c3 saving the pawn
rook there will be eight
well so far so good
will be b1 king f2
king d7
rook c5
hard to hard to say what was going on
here
uh the position is very
it seems quite complex i think black
should be i think black should be fine
though
but precision is required and let's not
forget they play uh
uh five plus one so okay the rook was
not doing
much on on h6 so it's time to
to move the rook away okay cheat knight
e4 now rook b8
and yeah okay okay now they
they just decide for for an ending this
ending should be should be equal
yeah okay so probably this is just a
draw
uneventful now
uh opposite card bishop well alice
unless
there is some there is some plunder here
but
i i don't know we will see
probably not so
just advancing the pawn
well white is a pawn up but it's uh
opposite card bishop
and that pawn on a3 is strong it
gives the white rook so basically the
the game is should be a draw yeah
loses the g pawn and um
now it's a draw of course they keep
playing it
okay this is not this is not so
interesting so let's move
let's move on to the next game
uh probably anyway probably i will not
have time to talk about
all the games it is taking longer than i
thought
so let's see hikaru white maxim black
the same opening
same as before so they're both happy
with
what they got i think white got a better
position in the first game
so let's see where maxim is going to
change
queen c7 e5
all right again he takes on d4 and
allows this
uh gives out the
[Music]
the pair of bishops 24 oh there we go
rook fc8 this is this is the new move
rook fc8
oh just uh just a moment because
i need to see with
i need to see where the chat does
i think i i think i did something wrong
with the chat
so
i want to
[Music]
i had i had a chat from the from the
previous stream so
i couldn't see the chat it was
from the previous stream i'm still not
very experienced with the
streaming on youtube so obviously
i couldn't see anything on the previous
chat so i had to i had to bring a new
chat
all right good
i'm back i'm back guys and now now i can
see
now i can see what uh what you're
writing there no
uh it's not live it's not live it was
played on sunday but
i'm reviewing the i'm reviewing the
most important games of the week so i'm
reviewing this uh this event
it's uh is the final between uh hikar
nakamura and
uh maxim vasya lagra and
hikaru nakamura won with 18.5
points versus 12 and a half so
bishop g5 once again the same idea
h6 bishop h4
[Music]
he's quite fond of it but i don't know
he's giving up the f4 square
queen of four there we go
queen d3
[Music]
knight f6 just defending against the
mate all right he's going for the ending
i think
the ending should be slightly better for
white but
probably not what you have in mind in a
bliss game you want to go for an attack
and especially now that
[Music]
we can see knight going to to e5
so rook d8 95
quincy five queen e2
well suddenly suddenly again i like
white's position so
i think something went very wrong with
black's position
like rook 81 is coming and we can see
once this knight arrived on e5
yeah it feels like something went wrong
with black's position
and maybe there is a threat of knight f7
i'm not sure
well he wasn't sure either but he
defended just in case
i think it's good okay rook d1
rook c8 and now
yeah now is that
that tricky moment when you have to do
something you feel like the position is
very good and you
you need to do something so what
does he come up with h3
all right maybe it's practical maybe
it's a practical move
97
yeah now the knight is coming tonight
and the knight is coming to f5 and
suddenly i think white should do
something quickly
maybe some bishop h4 but then g5 so it's
not clear
the bishop could so something like this
and
[Music]
knight f5 well
this weakness with g5 i don't know
it's not so clear he can he can actually
use it so
k2 knight f5
now it's again just uh
i think black should be fine now once
one he got with the knight to f5
so might have to do something faster
there
so of course they played and played and
it was a draw in the end
now it has to go back yeah this should
be this should be equal
so probably just
okay still the pair of bishops were
white and you can try
so let's see let's see this ending it
can be
it can be interesting
can be an instructive ending so knight
f4
bishop e4 f3
so okay now again now again i like
white's position
a little bit uh because the b5 pawn can
be
can actually be a weakness so white
could uh
white could start attacking it like
bishop b2 there we go
knight d6 93
again i don't want to analyze move by
move because this is a blitz you
you have to think logically but you also
have to to make moves
so maybe not the best but
good enough good enough moves and you
have to be
up to the task tactically when some
tactical
[Music]
opportunity arises you you have to go
for it
knight b7 okay this seems to be bad
for some reason and the reason was
knight before knight takes
here and now the b5 is
lost or otherwise
uh king goes to
king goes all the way to the center
all right so
opportunity missed as i was saying
one has to one has to look for
opportunities so 95
now he takes bishop takes
bishop c4 and yeah probably now he's
going to be
i mean in case of a bishop swap black
can go
f6 e5 and just
cover the d4 square
so yeah now now it's good for black
i guess just just a draw should be
i mean now now the p5 pawn is not in
danger anymore he can go
bishop c6 to defend it okay for now also
b3
is under attack and
yeah more or less i expect it to be a
quick draw
okay we will we will move on i mean i
think they
they played the no they didn't play so
much okay we can see it until then
yeah they just found the repetition i
mean yeah
game manager pro uh
all right all right interesting game
interesting game there are some missed
opportunities
so this was the third game let's see
some some decided games
let's try to skip the draws so fourth
game
just to get a feel for this for this
match to
to try to reach some conclusions so so
far i see that they both stick to their
openings they
they have their preferred openings and
they they go for it
they go for it and they are both uh they
are both happy with
the outcome of the opening
so then again the same variation
same line who is going to change first
rookie one okay i've already learned the
line h3 to force that bishop
h4 now g4
um yeah i don't know maybe
some more people will watch afterwards
because this this is not only just
probably because of that
all right g4
and now 97 yeah this this is like before
so let's see
just where this game went different
okay so now instead the previous game
was
the previous game was c4 here so now
he he switched to rook d4
okay some interesting idea
knight b6
94.
yeah usually the streams are at a later
time but i'm streaming from
from romania so it would be late for me
this this is a better hour for me but
people
people can watch afterwards
okay 94 what's going on
it seems that black is already in
trouble so
this position is actually dangerous i
don't know if hikaru should
should have gone for this or maybe he
needs to have some
some backup backup line
yeah probably so rook d8
yes and now of course
rook takes h4 is not possible because of
bishop g5 and these pawns are
white is going to to create a past
h pawn
so it's going to be trouble okay also
this knight on d5
looks uh looks good i don't know
probably white is going to to create a
passage pawn but
black will also be able to push and the
knight yet the knight looks good so
we have a game going on
c5 so maybe c4
a5 c5 b4
okay first coming with the king i think
white is better but
i don't know how much batter is is white
here
c4 looks good i mean now the knight is
uh
now the knight is defended there
i don't know yeah it seems more it seems
more okay rook b1 now
he switched over there but probably just
g5 h6 is not doing so much
not some not that much damage because
the pawn is not going to
to promote and black and play a5 b4
so vp1 g5
so this was the this was the mistake
probably it had to be prepared like
something else just not this was not the
moment
the moment to go before this was an
important moment
but there were a long time here so
already he goes b4 eager for counterplay
he goes b4 with idea then
to play c3 and do something there but
i guess it was better to to bring the
king to
to the king side or even a5 yes a5 could
be
could be a move i know g6
and yeah maybe now maybe now b4
it's strange strange position
but yeah i guess it's
better better for white take everything
and black has some kind of play here
i think anyway this was the way to go
and maybe because of this strong knight
it should be not but i'm not sure
really not sure but b4 was uh
it seems it was too too hard
c3 bishop e1 and yeah now we can see
because he cannot
he cannot take back the b pawn
so
well he could difficult to see the
consequences of
look here bishop c3
knight c2 king f4
[Music]
but this could just be this could just
be lost for
for black
okay he keeps the rooks knight f4
well yeah probably it was
it was strong also like this so now now
it's very difficult for black
so the ending what i'm trying to see is
how
also how they managed to get
these decisions and
the psychological point of view and also
what type type of openings they they
choose for this game so
yeah now now it's just over this uh
once the the rook got into play and uh
with these passports it's game over yeah
h6
he announced winning a piece
and uh yeah he just resigned here
all right nice game but i think
um hikaru got a bad position in in this
game probably he made some inaccuracy
early on
so the berlin world for for maxim
all right just uh let me see the next
game
okay some sound decide uh decided game
okay
so now hikaru lost
this one the next one so again we have
this setup
we're moving fast
and
well we already have some this already
became some
30 here d4 rook c8 okay he's trying to
improve like this
the thing is i don't think they they had
time in between the
the game so no time to
to improve e5
already we know this but i guess this is
a better form for
black and finally he takes on e5 he
doesn't allow
y to to take on d6 as before
paul takes yeah i'm curious how how this
is going to to be
knight g3 so just like that all right
he's trying to bring the knight to h5
maybe
and uh
he's going for king side attack maybe
play king queen e2 somewhere
knight f8 yeah it feels good to to cover
the king side
again very unclear position and um
they went out of uh
hikaru managed to get out of the opening
preparation
so it's just an over the board game and
[Music]
plenty of possibilities
well white what can i say is that this
rook only one i don't really like it
now he's going for a for an attack
i don't know if uh if it's enough i mean
he's missing the a1 rook so probably he
got tricked a little bit here
but
ah push the h point you mean
yes it's uh it's an idea but
how to do it i mean you cannot really
push the h-bone right now because it's
attacked and if you go g3 then you don't
want to weaken the
h18 diagonal
so he pushes f4 he needs to
okay and black also didn't have a clear
plan probably
he had to play more um
he had to find something concrete but
it's not easy
it was a difficult position it was a
difficult position and now he decides to
suck the exchange
if he takes here on f5 i don't know
bishop f5
it seems
this seems dangerous e6 could be next
this is dangerous so i
i completely understand him to take the
plane knight b3
attacking the rock
okay he has to take the knight thing
yeah here he played all right here is an
interesting moment actually
so that rook before that was uh
let me show you again i think that was
uh that was a nice move this rook before
especially for a police game i mean
talking about on please give this this
is a nice resource because you
you go for it and it means that you go
for
counter attack and now he's setting uh
problems
for white and white when rookie two and
yeah it was better to
uh
it was better to just continue to attack
with the
queen g4 something
harry before knight h6 d4
okay something like this something like
this was good
bishop g6 and it seems that this works
for white but
who would have thought about that it was
not
uh it was not easy something like this
and now yes
queen e6 or queen
queen g6 but yeah it was difficult to
decide upon this but
now rookie 2 the rook is completely
stuck there
who is this wrong magnus one day
who knows maybe hikaru maybe somebody
else maybe
fabiano caruana or maxim
we will see knight d4
queen g4 okay so now it's completely
black filed for um
for white
knight f5
and the rook is stuck there on a2
going for checkmate
from d8
bishop c5 yeah this uh
this is just lost now because of the
rook on
because of the rook on a2 so
that was a bad decision rook did too
well wow
beautiful very nice very nice especially
for
for a blitz game
uh wrecking your fate before yeah just
to bring the rook
into play but it's it's too late here
very very nice game
let's say this one and it was
we had missed opportunities
so okay we have a draw let's keep that
draw
maybe we have time for two or three more
games
so let's see hikaru coming back
afterwards
all right oh my the same variation
so look at this we skipped a draw there
was a game that ended in a draw we
skipped that because
okay he is not going to play d4 so early
because he's saying
okay maybe black can go rook c8 like in
that game
he wasn't happy with it and he first
brings the
knight to g3 h3 like a really low pass
with
for white royal open setup
and d4 okay also maybe
here it makes sense for black to go rook
c8
just to prevent d4 and then
and then i don't know i mean bishop b1
is too much probably
white has to to play something like
bishop
d2 or bishop e3 well
but anyway um our bishop is three
but anyway um
d4 would stop so i think rook ac8 could
could make sense bishop f8 because now
again d4
and yes after okay c8 now there is
bishop d3
more active so
uh this makes sense e5 yeah now we have
like a position of uh
from uh roy lopez but i guess uh hikaru
could have more experience here than
than maxim maybe maxim knows this from
white's point of view
but let's see anyway it's a it's a bliss
game so
probably this is slightly preferable for
white because
white can go for a kingside attack and
[Music]
he has more space also so
this can queen d2 he wants
probably he wants to exchange that dark
square bishop on g7
there we go
well yes this is this is an interesting
moment so
after such a move like f6 you
don't really feel like exchanging that
bishop on g7
but on the other hand if you don't do it
then you're stuck with the attack so
probably
probably it has to be done but he
he doesn't want to take on g7 by himself
well after f6 it's okay h4
finally pushing the a pawn and now we
can see the
black bishop on b7 is like a shot of
there
and well also black has that knight on
c5 so maybe
it all depends whether their attack is
going to be successful or not knight f8
this seems to be a mistake it was uh
maybe it was a better idea to take on a4
but i wouldn't consider such a move okay
knight f8 makes sense to me
and h5 but now
now black is uh
like is doing really bad
also there is a file for the for this
rook
so room v8 take take
well after taking he doesn't have the
options to go for h6 anymore but
he's just weakening black position
yeah the yes that was a good moment to
take on g7 and now
this this is a good game i i really
liked how he
how he built up the position until here
and look at this it's just winning and
it doesn't seem like it's winning but
it's actually
very bad for black now this there is a
double threat of knight f6 and knight h6
so king j7 rook is three look at this
all the pieces are into attack this
this is a very nice game i'm
i'm impressed i mean the pieces it seems
like
white spaces go by go by themselves
it all seems very natural
yeah this is he has to he has to give up
the
exchange now because if rookie seven
there is
among other moves let's say this
mission f5 knight f5 on tanks
and rg3
9g6 and i guess pawn takes on f5 yeah
it's just decisive so you see this
is
uh knight f6
knight f61 i don't think he missed
knight f6
knight h7 okay now he took
but this this is very beautiful game the
way
he the way he build up the the position
the whole position think
i would be i'd be proud to play such a
such a play such a gaming over the board
and
now he just resigns so it's just
crushing look at this the rooks are
coming from all the
directions rook g3 rook a7
yeah just great just great
okay so let's see how
what happened in the next game
so now after such a
such a nice game
it's difficult for maxim to he needs to
he needs to show some good chess and
look at this
he carries is changing from from the
berlin no more berlin
so now he is trying to to play something
else
this g6 tricky line he felt
the the psychological advantage here
so okay this is uh
not the best line for black in the rui
lopez but
it's perfectly playable
95 well i don't really know the details
here
as i'm not playing the royal opus
anymore
this h3 move makes sense to me because
bishop g4 looked annoying
but now it seems that black is doing
fine
so
maybe h3 was was weak
but yeah now now black is uh black is
getting a very good position
i mean very good normal
root d8 d5
well i wouldn't have played d5 i think
this is uh
i think this is a major decision
good to hear that somebody just saying
that
they got stalemated because of my
previous
lesson so yeah
i think i think white just had to to
keep the center together like
rook c1 or rook e1 or
anything else but not to close the
position
it seems it seems way too early to do it
knight c4 obviously the knight
didn't belong to a5 so you you want to
bring this knight into play
knight e3 that that's a risky decision
but if black manages to to exchange this
knight in
then it's very good i wonder what
happens to bishop d3
so just c4 and actually now this knight
is
strong because black black and you can
just push over there so rook c1
uh knight a3 well knight is three yes
it's uh
it's a big decision but because the
knight could get
stuck there but it also uh supports the
the c pawn the the c
pushing the c point so yeah now y
doesn't doesn't look good oh
f5 major decision again it seems that
e5 could be possible but i don't know
take 95
well these are difficult tactics too to
see
so i5 seems like a good idea in a blitz
but yeah e5 was
strong
and now now finally the initiative
goes to goes to black
um although his king could be a bit
weakened but look at this
d5 pawn is d5 pawn is weak
bishop uh v7 yeah he goes for the d5
pawn
yeah d5 is weak and once once d5 pawn
falls falls apart and
the whole position is falling apart so i
think it paid off for
for hikaru to play a bit more risky
because he felt like
the game was going his own way oh look
at this
completely
ah there is beautiful bishop f3 here
yeah no no now black black is winning
there is this bishop f3 very important
detail and
queen is three what now oh
of course he just gives off the queen
for two rooks
two rooks and uh bishop yeah it's
decisive
his decisive advantage so the only worry
is that this bishop on d1 is somehow
stuck
and you don't really want to lose the g6
pawn
so he has to defend it queen d3
okay i think he's going to give up the
bishop from d1
just pushing
black extra opponent center yeah extra
opponent center and this
center is uh
um is going to decide again yeah
yeah the pawns are just marching off
yeah
it's decisive very very good very good
game
very good game and i think in this game
hikaru
got the right moment to to play for for
a win
even with black i mean he changed from
the berlin
he changed to another opening and
he immediately got a very good position
from it so
i i guess this this worked for him
and uh yeah we we didn't uh manage to
look at all the games but that was not
the point
in the end in the five plus one section
it was uh five and a half to
four and a half for
hikaru nakamura but
[Music]
in the other sections he he just played
better and in the end he
won with 18 and a half to 12 and a half
and he managed to win this very strong
tournament
the speed just
[Music]
turned tournament all right so
very very nice games okay there was also
mistakes but
uh that is part of the game
and i think the level was uh was good
even in this
five plus one games
um great great victory by
hikar nakamura to
to clinch this uh this trophy
uh this is uh this is all for now i hope
you enjoyed the
the games and um
see you next time it was mircha parli
grass
bye bye